hey youtubers it's Charlie so for the
past week Stephen Amell and the CW have
been dropping a whole bunch of arrow
season 3 bombs we know about four new
characters including some new details
about the Harley Quinn character as it
relates to the Suicide Squad in season 3
so I'm gonna be doing a breakdown of all
that stuff hello to all the new people
who are just finding me for the first
time I hope you guys are having a great
summer but I'm gonna be doing DC and
Marvel bonus videos every week
especially for the TV shows and the
movies that are gonna be happening in
the fall be sure to subscribe to get
everything feel free to leave me
suggestions for any bonus videos if
there's something that you guys really
really want to talk about speaking of
which let's talk about some of those new
arrow characters so these are all based
on network descriptions that the CW has
released so some of these are a little
bit silly just because they're official
news releases it's not like someone
speaking to you but here's the first one
his name is Daniel Daniel is a handsome
enigmatic and highly intelligent
entrepreneur developing groundbreaking
technology then in quotation marks it
says picture of businessman with Ryan
Gosling's body which i think is kind of
silly though exuding charm and
confidence in public he privately
harbors a tragic past that will drive
him to become a tech powered superhero
watch out for this formidable fella to
become a love interest for Felicity and
a rival of Oliver's both personally and
professionally so this is a pretty big
deal and right now he's just screaming
the daniel garrett version of the Blue
Beetle that's the Golden Age version of
the character he first appeared in
comics in 1939 in Mystery Men he wasn't
like the Ted Kord Blue Beetle he was a
police officer that took a serum to make
him super strong and wore a bulletproof
costume whatever he fought crime so that
doesn't sound exactly like the casting
description that they released so it's
possible that they're taking aspects of
that character like the name and
combining him with the Ted Kord Blue
Beetle or they're just using the daniel
name to throw people off and it really
will be ted kord because court
industries is a really big deal on arrow
they're the ones that made that mega
centrifuge that Slade stole to mass
produced the mirakuru and Queen
industries research department has been
doing business with him for a long time
Ted Kord could also be one of the ways
that Oliver it gets his company back -
he's one of the few other DC superheroes
that has a ton of money if you guys
aren't familiar with the character or
you didn't see him on Smallville
he's like a
hank pym type character not quite up to
the level of Tony Stark or Bruce Wayne
in terms of wealth and popularity but he
still has a really massive company the
Ted Kord of the comics was a little bit
of a sillier superhero he did have an
ongoing relationship with Barbara Gordon
when she was Oracle his version of the
Blue Beetle was never able to unlock the
powers of the Scarab that was something
that Jamie Rhys character did after he
took up the mantle remember DC tried to
do a pilot for that TV show a long time
ago so once upon a time there was going
to be a Blue Beetle TV show on the CW
but the pilot never made it to series
looking at the origin of that character
might offer some clues about the villain
this season to Ted Kord became the lu
beetle after Daniel Garrett died in
battle they were investigating Ted
kord's uncle Jarvis Kord he was trying
to build an army of androids to take
over the world
arrow has a long history of changing
characters backstories and just kind of
mixing and matching things from the
comic books so don't be surprised if
they take aspects of the Daniel Garrett
Blue Beetle and Ted Kord and combine
them but I do expect that we will see
imagery for the Scarab the cool thing
about them developing the Blue Beetle
character on the show and having Amanda
Waller is now they have a back door to
Maxwell Lord and checkmate
Smallville did checkmate already so
arrow might wait a little while but
before doing their version of it but
it's another big organization that will
definitely make an appearance at some
point at least in a future season the
funny thing about this is that I can
already see the Daniel Felicity tumbler
ship sailing I can only imagine how
that's gonna affect all the olicity
shippers I feel for you guys I feel for
you it seems like the flash TV show is
gonna be pushing the Barry Irish
relationship so it makes sense that
arrow would start pushing for Daniel and
Felicity or Felicity with someone else
I've got my fingers crossed that he
actually ends up joining Team arrow by
the mid-season finale just like Barry
Allen did just in case it's not Blue
Beetle there are a couple other
possibilities for who that character
could be Daniel could be mr. terrific or
he could be Daniel Cassady aka the Blue
Devil as we saw on the bus in season two
but none of those characters fit the
description as well as Blue Beetle Ted
Kord or Daniel Garrett so I'm gonna
stick with that he is Blue Beetle
remember in season two Isabel rochev was
Ravager without being Rose Wilson so
arrow does change things
the second new character is named Seth
and here's the network character
description a well-educated crimine
with grand ambitions and a knack for
chemistry this potentially recurring
character gains power over his enemies
by exposing them to a drug that drains
their willpower oh and he is very much a
physical match for the arrow so the
closest people that that sounds like art
of the Scarecrow and parasite but
because the Jonathan cranes scarecrow
character was never really a physical
match for any of the other big
superheroes in the DC Universe and
because the parasite isn't really
someone who uses chemistry
it could be someone completely different
or an original creation of the show
based on the description it sounds like
he's going to occupy that bill in
position in the story that brother blood
had in season two like the villain that
we see first but then later a bigger
villain emerges from the shadows the
next two characters are both Hong Kong
flashback characters or at least
characters that will mostly see in Hong
Kong flashbacks named tashi and Akiko
here's the character descriptions Tashi
will serve as Oliver's teacher and
handler and eventually become a friend a
well trained operative skilled in
weaponry combat and intelligence
gathering he is also a devoted father
and husband Akiko is his wife in another
of Oliver's honk-honk caretakers and
herself highly skilled in martial arts
so Tasha sounds like he might be an
original creation of the show like a
prequel version of Diggle it's possible
that those characters will be the
inspiration for the modern-day version
of team arrow a lot of superheroes like
Batman tend to work alone
Oliver chooses to work with a team for a
reason so the Hong Kong flashbacks this
season will probably explain why that is
the akiko character is a little bit more
exciting because she could potentially
be Lady Shiva which I know everyone has
been asking about this year or katana
the katana character just got a new
comic book series that launched around
the same time the new vibe comic
launched and that character is a regular
on the flash TV show so katana also
appears in the new 52 version of the
birds of prey comic which Blue Beetle
has also appeared in not a new 52 but
the Blue Beetle has been in birds of
prey previously we already know that
arrow is going to be doing more birds of
prey stories in season 3 so I'm gonna
stick with katana as being the best
choice for this akiko character and just
because those two characters are
flashback characters doesn't mean we
will not see them in present-day
I've got my fingers crossed for a
present-day Hong Kong or China trip
because they didn't go to Russia in
season two so here's a big update on
as it relates to the Suicide Squad in
season 3 Stephen Amell was at Phoenix
Comic Con recently and he said that he's
really hoping to get Harley Quinn out of
her cell in season 3 and on the Suicide
Squad it sounds like the show is going
to try and use her if everything behind
the scenes works out part of the issue
with them using comic book characters is
that they have to get clearance from
Warner Brothers they can't just cast
Batman or Nightwing or anyone they want
without getting approval even though
Warner Brothers owns arrow the show the
characters and the network that it airs
on it's a bit of a mess but if Stephen
Amell is bugging them behind the scenes
there's a much better chance that it's
gonna happen Cassidy Alexa for those who
don't know played her on screen played
part of Quinn on screen and Tara Strong
did the voice for it was like a Darth
Vader thing where you have an actor
playing the body and someone else doing
the voice Stephen Amell said this funny
thing that when it comes to TV if it
looks good it has a much better chance
of happening and I think that everyone
agreed that Cassidy Alexis version of
Harley Quinn was pretty awesome so I'm
expecting to hear more about it at Comic
Con in production related news arrow
season 3 starts shooting three weeks
from today so hopefully once they start
filming outdoor scenes we'll get a look
at some of those new characters but I'll
be doing bonus videos every week from
now until season 3 comes so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and feel
free to leave me suggestions for bonus
topics is there something that you guys
really really want to talk about another
DC news Jason Momoa is supposedly going
to be Aquaman in the Batman vs Superman
movie it's not confirmed so I wasn't
planning on doing a video there was a
bunch of details leaked about the plot
of Avengers 2 so that's probably gonna
be the next video I do supposedly a
bunch of the plot leaked so I'll be
putting a bunch of spoiler warnings
whenever I do that video I'll try and
post that by tonight right now click
here to learn more about arrow season 3
and here to learn more about Avengers 2
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight high fives
you